all right Candace is with us in
Indianapolis hi Candace how are you I'm
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up I need some help my
husband has two jobs right now and he's
trying to figure out which one he should
take okay the first one is where he is
now he is a maintenance supervisor he
makes 60 K annually salary position but
their insurance is expensive and it has
a history of just increasingly the
premiums go up all insure all insurance
does okay and so he just got a call back
from a company that he was with before
that he had he had left because he went
to second shift there and it didn't work
with our family and they are offering
him to come on at fifty-six annually and
that's with no overtime but they work
mandatory seven days a week right now in
their busy season and he could make
upwards of ninety ka here and their
insurance is about 120 dollars weekly
where the other company's insurance is
about 400 bi-weekly
so he's just kind of torn the the
insurance doesn't matter a question is
where would heal a rather work which
group of people that and that's where
he's kind of torn as well the the job
that is calling him back is an hour away
from us and the job that he's at now is
about a 20 minute drive so um we're what
takes him to where he wants to be five
years from now how old is he he's 31
what's he want to be when he's 40 well
he has the last we talked it was a
supervisor which is what he has now
right well that's not what he wants to
be when he's 40 then yes he doesn't want
to grow at all what's right go ahead
what's he want to be when he's 40 and a
blast we talked his five to 10-year plan
was he wanted to be a supervisor in a
maintenance at UM for maintenance and
have a team that he uh was able to
direct which he does
now yes okay in either of these jobs
well the job the job that's an hour away
is what he would be an electrician for a
main plant for this company so he would
not be a supervisor there no but the
reason he's looking towards that
position that job is because it will
allow us to get our debts paid off
faster because of the seven days a week
mandatory so works on our option okay
keep the good job the one that's close
and pays more uh-huh and the insurances
are relevant because they're both going
to go up they're both kind of you know
until Obamacare gets completely undone
you're not going to see your premiums do
anything so shoot through the roof it's
what we've seen for ever since it came
into play and it's not a political
statement it's just a freakin fact and
so um it's you know so that that's it
you know you're going to have insurance
issues wherever you are the other job
sounds like he's doing what he wants to
be doing what his plan was and all he's
doing is taking a step back here and
driving an hour away to get some
overtime okay did I miss something no no
that's exactly where we've kind of been
kind of ping Polly coming back now I'm
not going to take a step back for the
opportunity to work overtime and drive
an extra hour so but what I would do is
to start developing a side game plan and
say okay if I'd like to have another
thirty thousand dollars a year coming in
but I'm willing to work seven days a
week what can I do on the side to start
my own weekend thing with my skills that
I have he's obviously an electrician he
could do some things there you know work
what can he pick up until he gets out of
debt and then doesn't work because you
only want to work the overtime till he
got out of debt right then more seven
days rest of his life
correct yeah so I mean you can pick up
another thirty thousand fifteen twenty
thousand work inside stuff especially
with his skills and then I think beyond
that you need to ask another question
and that is where do you want to be when
you're 40 okay not doing the exact same
thing right I'll be growing and doing
more we'll be making 90 I want to be
making 120 I want to be and why and what
do I want to do I mean you need to have
some kind of a goal that
stretches you and causes you to read and
grow and learn and take classes and be
better at what you do and maybe you're
running a bigger maintenance operation I
don't care maybe he's running the entire
facility or something not just a
supervisor I don't care
but let's lay out some stuff here that
that we're aiming at something and then
that also helps you make your short-term
decisions does this take me to where I
want to go and that's where we are hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]